as we await the possible First Federal
and second overall indictment and arrest
of the twice impeached once indicted
failed former president Donald Trump
some devastating news to Trump Has
Broken
and that is that Mark Meadows his own
former Chief of Staff has already
testified has already testified we are
going to look at a report about this and
discuss why it is such a big deal
Newsweek reports Donald Trump suffers
the worst hit yet in string of legal
blows and it reads Donald Trump is
facing further legal headaches amid
suggestions his former Chief of Staff
has testified to a grand jury as part of
two Federal investigations into the
former president remember there are two
Federal investigations into Trump one
relates to the document Fiasco
Mar-A-Lago Bedminster the drained pool
into the surveillance room that entire
thing that alone is Bonkers then there's
the additional federal investigation
related to what the January 6th
committee from the last Congress
referred to the justice department
involving January 6 the Trump riots Etc
back to the article several media
Outlets have reported that Mark Meadows
has answered questions under oath after
being subpoenaed by special counsel Jack
Smith he's leading the probes into
Trump's attempts to overturn 2020 and
his actions on January 6th and the
classified documents Meadows is said to
have answered questions relating to both
criminal investigations into the former
president while appearing in front of
the grand jury per ABC News Meadows has
long been considered a key figure in the
criminal investigation into these events
Meadows has gained additional
significance as part of the classified
documents probe after reports emerged
remember we covered this last week that
there is audio of trump admitting in
July of 2021
he had retained a Secret Pentagon paper
and it was classified which confirms
that Trump didn't actually believe that
he had Declassified it so let's cut
right to the chase with this because
there's really like the the core kernel
of this at the center why is the
testimony of Mark Meadows so potentially
disastrous for Donald Trump Meadows at
the critical moment
at which all of this stuff was going on
was Trump's closest Ally and confidante
in the white house we know this there's
no doubt about it whatsoever Meadows
knows everything about Trump's attempts
to overturn the 20 election 2020
election to incite the January 6th
Insurrection he certainly knows about
Trump's apparently and potentially
illegal retention retention of
classified documents which has all sorts
of different implications and so it is
The Meadows testimony above anyone else
we can even hypothetically think of that
could be the crucial evidence not by
itself but in addition to everything
else provided by other Witnesses and
other testimony for these two Federal
investigations being led by special
counsel Jack Smith this really is the
nightmare scenario for Donald Trump
trump has been desperately trying
to avoid scrutiny of course but to avoid
accountability and legal Jeopardy for
his actions he has said he had the
authority to declassify any document he
wanted even if he didn't have access to
them or even if he didn't have the legal
right to do so but then we figured out
oh he knowingly said I have classified
documents after this period where the
supposed declassification took place
Meadows is the top guy
who can testify to what Trump believed
new thought and said at the time
remember that Trump also tried to block
former aides from cooperating with
Congress and with the justice department
he tried invoking these bogus claims of
executive privilege and threatening
people with lawsuits and he even quite
frankly he even seemed to have uh
potentially
um uh witness tampering okay there are
allegations that there was witness
tampering although that's something that
has to be proven in court so we'll stop
there but the Trump legal strategy
doesn't appear to have actually worked
courts have repeatedly rejected his
claims of privilege and Immunity they've
allowed prosecutors and investigators to
access documents and Witnesses and when
we talk about Meadows uh they want to
talk to Steve Bannon and on and on
this is potentially the one individual
who could most jeopardize Donald Trump
legally this is the most serious legal
Peril that Trump has faced in his life
he has only himself to blame he's abused
power
he's violated his oath of office he's
certainly betrayed the country he's
endangered countless lives in many
different ways and he forget about
remorse forget about repentance he
doesn't even pretend to be sorry for any
single aspect of this and only blames
other people and says he's the biggest
victim in the world
so the news of Mark Meadows reportedly
testifying could be the most devastating
single event in the entire series of
trump investigations and we will soon
but by the time this video and this
episode publish we may already know more
about the Trump Federal indictment than
we know right now